previously on TV since you really should
just call me Simon I like to do drawings
[Music]
[Applause]
come on ladies show use his same high
school name from The Wonder Years and
then later Gleek what is it about
William McKinley in coming-of-age shows
also President McKinley was from Ohio
there's no way a Michigan school is
going with a guy from the state that
shall not be named when Gerald Ford's an
option we just saw coach Biff get on a
player for not being on the field so why
does this Romeo get to skip out it's his
position on the team starting plot
convenient sir it's just that I love you
so much
scares me Ashley and Brett he really
like Bill Murray don't you of all the
things I was bullied for in school I can
guarantee you that my level Bill Murray
was not one of them man high school
considering Linda Cardellini was 24 when
she shot this I'm just impressed she
still remembers high school wait where
did that sky-blue background come from
just a second ago she sat down in front
of what can only be described as a
gigantic sandpaper bath towel and now
she's Linda in the Sky with Diamonds
this is not how picture day works since
you would be generally called by class
there is no way for our main characters
to be shot in order opening credits
sequence contains no Becky and Baker or
Joe Flaherty this yearbook page could
never exist
shouldn't it be alphabetized by class
how would Sam's picture be on the same
page as his sister who was two years
older than him let alone on the same
page as Harry Osborne Marshall Eriksen
and the Green Hornet you know I ran into
mrs. Patton today farmer Jack rest in
peace farmer Jack I guess it's not
always savings time after all I had a
friend it used to smoke you know what
he's doing now he's dead I think smoking
makes you look cool let's go dig him up
now and see how cool he loves my mom
would use the Adam Walsh story to make
me scared to leave her side and grocery
stores when I was a kid just sing a
tease parents were up when it came to
teaching lessons and that's totally
worth a sit lima beans I'm sorry did I
crush it pop quiz I'm sorry did I crush
your Twinkies was a a sports bra company
slogan be what the hostess delivery man
said to me yesterday when he dropped off
my monthly supply see the name of my
Christian a grotesque effusion band in
high school or D what busy Phillip
should say sarcastically to Seth Rogen
after she kicks him in the nuts for
grabbing her ass later also if this
bully bullied any harder his name would
have to be bulimic bullets in the third
what are you
- crying - your sister Sam rear Sam rear
there's no way this 80s asshat doesn't
go with Sam queer there not a chance and
yes of course that's offensive but isn't
that the point
that's womanist hardy-har someone
changed the sign to say trash instead of
trash we can even see they put the H
down there in the corner but why
wouldn't you just go on the way and take
the T in the arm as well I mean if
you're gonna do it why not at least put
in a little effort oh sorry your butt
was calling to me 1980s but dials were a
lot more inappropriate than today these
three in this show together with Apatow
and feed all just getting their start
just kind of boggles the mind
this single show could be considered
solely responsible for the existence of
40 year old virgin knocked up
funny people Superbad Pineapple Express
forgetting sarah marshall this is the
end bridesmaids and an app a ton of
other things - some great some good some
not so much but if you do the math I'm
guessing it all adds up to at least five
cents off dad's making you go to the
dance and what's that all about
who's your dad we got Hitler jokes y'all
just go sucks I hate this guy between
this last days of disco and Detroit Rock
City there was a lot of disco bashing in
the late 90s wait maybe that's not a sin
but without disco we'd have no knock on
wood so my hands are tied friend of
yours
okay kid tries to fit in with the cool
kids but first has to distance him or
herself from the old nerdy friends by
hurting their feelings cliche or
stranger is made to fight a school
computer this sure was truly funny but
the first 12 minutes has pretty much
been a series of references where
everyone watching in 1999 could think
hey remember when computers were scarce
or Caddyshack was a thing where people
thought John Francis Daley would be the
breakout star of this show you should
handle Allen same way Han Solo dealt
with Jabba the Hutt step on his tail and
beg him for more time all right your
addition wasn't special also if this is
the fall of 1980 he's certainly seen
Empire by now as far as he knows that
strategy ends up with Solo encased in
carbonite forever with no one ever
knowing how a random border guard gave
him his name oh yeah that's real great
you know why don't you blow your nose
and some bread and make me a sandwich
too busy Phillips is awesome and the
fact that she seems to be mostly known
these days as Michelle Williams plus one
at awards ceremonies feels like a sin
I'm sorry
let's be friends what is up with all the
paper mrs. green book is carrying around
is she attending a ticker-tape parade
later
chanson the party feels like the
equivalent of Sigourney Weaver's
character in Galaxy Quest he has one job
to do so he's going to make sure he does
it over and over again
I got a teacher would put all the
scrawny nerds on one team and all the
jocks on the other all right why did the
whole game just stop for this moment I'm
sure some of those balls have bounced
back and play for the other side and
they've been flying so fast and furious
before this is where I've been diesel
was involved and to think I used to root
for that kid when he played goalie for
the Ducks
shame on you Goldberg shame all the way
on you highlight Ben Foster as much as
the next guy but man this episode goes
through hell and high water to hammer
home the special needs abuse where the
homophobic slurs and political stabs not
enough seriously this Eli shaming is all
over this pilot let's just go ahead and
tack on ten cents actually yes you most
definitely are even in 1980 we seem to
be playing by the social-media rules of
shaming is it a boy no hey you can tell
me discount Chris Elliott here is the
guidance counselor who cares a little
too much you know instead of the
guidance counselor who doesn't care at
all which according to TV are apparently
the only two choices you do know that
there are occasionally counselors that
care the exact right amount in the world
that might be an actual help to students
if you work too busy scaring them off
from actually seeking it out right TV
are you looking for a fight dork sudden
convenient bully is suddenly convenient
all right after class you and me are
cutting out of here Nick should say it a
little louder there might be a couple
teachers in the school that didn't hear
yeah I got something to show you it's
gonna make you feel better and this kids
is how I Met Your Mother
six more pieces I got a bigger keeping
neopor from Rush the biggest kit Peart
ever played was about 40 pieces and you
just said you had 14 mounted toms eight
floor toms four splashes two gongs ten
cowbells for rides five snares one roto
Tom rack and for kick drums I hired
someone to do the math and it appears
you've already got 52 pieces meaning you
were drummed up tomfoolery about meeting
Maureen fooling anyone around here I
can't make you be a mathlete but I can
make you work the refreshment table at
the homecoming dance can you know why
would one extracurricular activity be
different from another wait a minute you
guys fought Alan no we got hit by a car
PFC Hirschberg would be geektastic
at TV since they've picked up sticks
come sail away to play here and with all
the top-notch licensed music in this
thing I'm starting
wonder if they are going to have enough
money to make a season two no balls you
can't wear stuff like that at church man
the best art is understood by the fewest
number of people for the greenskeeper
now about to become the Masters champion
I just got first hair on Bowl you're the
Africa girl right yeah
I'm Kevin and poor captain of the North
Shore mathletes just mears the whole
world suck it's so hard here because I
would always see my cereal boxes open
and the cereal would get stale and so
one day I can't hold it at this waiting
for me just keeps my cereal fresh but
now I have the freshest cereal and it's
all mounted on my infamous quadruple
kick drum system six more pieces I got a
bigger kick the Neil Peart from Rush I
couldn't used a little more cowbell
Randy lay there like a slug it was his
only defense my mother would not approve
this coach she's like me to live to be
bar Mitzvahed